Sam Ramey reveals Peter in Harry's
window with a similar camera move that
he did for Doc Ock in the previous film
and then they fight
protected you in high school now I'm
gonna kick your little ass Peter's
reaction is actually hilariously sincere
because back when Peter did get jumped
in high school Harry stayed on the
sidelines
which one and Peter taunts look at
little Goblin Jr
I'm gonna cry and then he flings the
grenade back at Harry torching Harry's
face the same way Norman did to Peter in
the Final Act of the first film and you
can actually see Harry's body going
flying as just Peter walks away ouch
laughs
[Music]